islamist terror a global threat
in the interview the middle east analyst
guido steinberg
mr steinbeck a terrorist attacked the
canadian parliament this week there were
several deaths the man had an islamist
background but apparently he acted
single-handedly how can a state protect
itself from such lone attackers
basically there's no protection against
lone attackers
if they do most of their planning in
secret the security agencies have almost
nothing to go on
but in recent years we've seen again
that our security agencies haven't even
been able to stop those they are aware
of
for instance after being prevented from
going to syria from becoming active as
terrorists
let's take a look at syria and iraq
where the terrorist militia islamic
state is fighting for power
how was this group of jihadis able to
become so strong
to start with there were political
mistakes and the biggest one was made by
the
government withdrawal in 2011 it did
after
iraqi
everything to keep the sunnis and the
secularists who'd been elected by many
sunnis away from power
it began persecuting sunni politicians
and also persecuted members of tribal
militias that the americans had
recruited
the result was that large parts of the
sunni population in western and
northwestern iraq saw the government now
in 2014 as their greatest enemy
and on top of that the syrian civil
the war of state structures in the
neighboring country encouraged this
situation
iraq turkey in the north a nato partner
why is ankara so reluctant to move
against is why are they just letting it
happen
simply has very different aims
there are two priorities for ankara
to topple the assad regime in damascus
the neo-ottomanist foreign policy of
erdogan's government in recent years has
in practice failed and the toppling of
assad could perhaps be the last success
to aim for
secondly it's a question of curtailing
the kurdish pkk
and the syrian kurds belong to this
organization
and only then comes the war against i.s
it seems as if the turkish government is
not taking this fight as seriously as we
are and in the end this leads to an
appearance that it is in fact supporting
that organization
some things have changed in the past
year and a half but we can still talk
about passive support or tolerance if
this continues it will be really
difficult to act against is effectively
without determined help from turkey
there are a lot of foreigners in the is
ranks europeans and americans is it
possible to calculate how many
so we have to assume a low four-digit
number who have been part of is since
2013.
what's worrying about the past months is
that this number keeps increasing
it's a proper jihadist international
that's come together could you explain
how this happened how did this movement
of political islam become so
internationalized
at the time it was still an exclusively
arab organization al-qaeda which was
strongly dominated by egyptians and
saudis but since then we've seen that
the scene has become very
internationalized
for example kurds and turks have joined
afghans pakistanis but also many
europeans including european converts
this has to do with two things with the
ideology which is by principle
internationalistic
i think it also has to do with a certain
susceptibility within the diaspora
somebody who lives in a diaspora is
already caught between two societies per
se the homeland and the country where he
now lives
and this internationalist idea has a
strong resonance
it's stronger in germany than in egypt
for instance
but mainly there are the western
interventions
and we're seeing their impact at the
moment especially in iraq and syria
the u.s british intervention in iraq the
destruction of state structures is the
cause of what we're experiencing at the
moment
not only the strengthening of terrorist
organizations but the quasi formation of
a state that has managed to destroy
national borders at least between iraq
and syria
in your book al qaeda's german fighters
you talk about the lives of jihadis has
a particular profile become apparent are
there typical international jihadis
who's going to war there international
jihadist
the national profile has completely
disappeared
in germany in 2006 and seven it seemed
as if many turks or kurds were joining
the jihadis but that immediately stopped
they're from all over
but they tend to be young and they're
getting younger and now there are women
too
they're from all levels of society
but at least when it comes to the events
in syria and iraq one has to say that
there has been a social shift
in 2001 al-qaeda was more of a
middle-class phenomenon there were many
students from the arab world
and this is very understandable in
europe
they come from the difficult districts
of cities such as brussels berlin
how do these jihadis organize themselves
does it all go via the internet
no we know very precisely in terms of
europe
it's less the internet that leads to
radicalization and recruitment
definitely doesn't take place via the
internet
it's
a small group develops the idea of going
to syria or to iraq or to somalia or
pakistan
we shouldn't ignore these other war
zones
the police and the security agencies are
now warning against the dangers posed by
people who've returned people who fought
in afghanistan or syria dangers for the
west how do you see this threat is it
latent
i think the events in ottawa show very
clearly what the threat looks like at
the moment
even though there are still unknowns i
think we can talk of a jihadist
background
there's a big danger posed by the high
number of people returning
in every european and western country
we're talking about three-digit numbers
here in germany there are over 400
people who've gone to syria or iraq at
some point in the past three years
and it'll be almost impossible for our
security agencies to process these high
numbers
in canada we've seen that there was
information but not enough capacity
in the next few years it'll be a
question of boosting staff and funds
but we also have to make our security
agencies more professional
to orient them towards a new threat
that's not so different from that post
by those who returned from pakistan for
instance
but one that's much bigger and more
difficult to overcome
how should the west america and the
european union deal with the region what
has to change from a political point of
view
to begin with we have to get used to the
idea that there are countries in the
region which will remain unstable for a
long time
i'm thinking mainly of syria
the civil war will probably last some
time and that will offer almost perfect
conditions for the activities of the
jihadists
that means we're looking at a long-term
danger threatening us from the arab
world
and i think that the most important step
is to bring turkey into line with the
americans so that it's possible to fight
is more effectively
it won't succeed without turkey
secondly there's still some hope that
iraq will become stable
the europeans in particular should do
more there those who basically washed
their hands of iraq for 11 years at
least those who didn't get involved in
the war
basically it's a question of stabilizing
the neighboring countries which are not
necessarily so directly affected now but
are is targets
i'm thinking of lebanon jordan and
possibly saudi arabia
we're going to have to work more closely
with them
at the same time this has to be linked
to a demand that they change their
domestic policies so that they can stay
stable in the long term
your employer the german institute for
international and security affairs
advises the german government are you
sometimes asked how the wars are
changing the map in the middle east and
will the states still look the same
after the wars
yes that is something people ask me
i'm a bit skeptical when they start
announcing the death of certain states
in the region
so far there's only one border that's in
huge danger the one between iraq and
syria
but we have at least one state iraq
where there's still a great deal of
nationalism iraqi nationalism and not
arab nationalism
if this state implements correct good
policies towards sunnis and uses its
resources reasonably and works on the
raging corruption
then there's a good chance these borders
will endure
but in some cases only if there are
federal solutions like for the kurds in
iraq
it will also be necessary to think about
how syria could look when that war does
finally end
it probably won't survive in its current
form
with the other states i think that we
can count on the borders lasting for a
long time
terrorism and political islam expert at
the german institute for international
and security affairs in berlin thank you
for answering our questions
thank you